it was an unprecedented show of unity
the 2015 Paris climate agreement the
worlds aren't fair to climate change the
u.s. may have were gone from the
agreement but others are sticking to the
plan the EU has ambitious goals in
reducing greenhouse gas emissions a cut
of 40 percent by 2030 compared to 1990
levels across all sectors it's a tall
order but not impossible
any peas are combing through the effort
shearing regulation the centrepiece of
Europe's efforts to implement the goals
of the Paris deal covering up to 60% of
total EU emissions this will include
sectors such as building agriculture
waste management small industry and
transport industries not covered by the
2005 emissions trading system we have to
take climate change even more seriously
than we're already doing we have to step
up our efforts in Europe as well in
order to stay within the boundaries of
the Paris agreement as the name implies
each EU country will carry their fair
share of the burden binding national
targets will be set wealthier nations
have to cut more for our countries will
get some leeway the European Parliament
interests that common climate goals
should precede national interests the
law aims to cut up to 100 million tons
of co2 emissions a gargantuan task to
put Europe well on its way towards a
low-carbon economy
[Music]